one I wanted to Spotlight how young this
Memphis team is I think it's kind of
been a part of the storyline we think
about the thunder we think about the
magic the Grizzlies almost 95 percent of
their points are coming from players 27
or younger they do not have a player on
the roster that is 30 years old this is
a very young team throughout this season
we've had different players that have
spoke out I just want to go to you first
Jamal about you being kind of an older
brother and so that's kind of how I want
the energy to be here speaking to a
younger brother that is part of this
incredible League that we all love what
would you say to jaw at a time like this
and with everything that's going on well
first off I think accountability is
always the best thing in this situation
and the statement that I saw he didn't
come out and try to sugarcoat it he
didn't say you know it was this or that
he said it was me I need to get help and
he owned it and with that I think if you
take that approach obviously what he did
was wrong
obviously it was a bad decision but
with that the accountability if you if
you accept it and learn from it then it
wasn't a loss it was a lesson and that's
what I'm hoping comes out of this
because he's a good kid I was making you
know not so smart decisions at 21 22
years old so I get that part but it's
not a loss it's a lesson if you learn
from it I love that he was accountable
but I think this is where vets are so
important I think there's vets in the
locker room it doesn't even get to this
point a vet's in the locker room like yo
Young fella slow down a little bit do
this this way move this way and that's
what I think is missing
um
it was a bad choice it was a bad
decision
you know we have to stop
looking at camera and says we have to
stop putting ourselves in positions to
where
they could take away what we've worked
so hard to get to
you should always believe in a higher
power
I've always had the ability to stop time
and say if I do this
what's going to be the outcome
it's no excuse for what he did but
remember he pressed the button on his
phone
he went live we don't go live nobody
knows he has a weapon we're not talking
about this but he did that
and you know why are you in the strip
club with no shirt
while you're walking around with a
weapon and why'd you hit the live button
so we have to stop putting ourselves in
positions to where they can take away
the things that we work hard to get for
I've seen your videos where your dad had
to a little cord and he training you and
your brothers and I've also seen the
video where your mom and dad that got
the nice mansion right next door to you
that's what we're trying to get to and
once we get there
we know the letter of the law we know
not what not to do what not to say and
we know Common Sense
think of the higher power
like I feel for him now but also feel
for his mother and father
hey what are they going through so you
so guys before you make a dumb decision
not a mistake a dumb decision a dumb
Choice think of the higher power
your mother your father your children
I'm not going to jump on a kid he know
what we did was wrong but remember
he put himself in the position he didn't
have to go live you got to pick your
phone up swipe to find Instagram get on
Instagram swipe again hit the live
button wait for it to connect are you
sure you want to go live you got to have
enough common sense to know that wasn't
gonna go the way you wanted it to go
you're not a rapper your NBA player
okay I don't know where you're from I
don't know who's hanging out with you
that don't matter
get when it's you making the decision
you got to be smart and we got to stop
putting ourselves in position to where
they can take it back now forget all the
investigation I don't like to hear
what's Nike going to do
what's the other company gonna do
we already seen the other situation
where one of our guys lost 30 million
like you don't want to see a young kid
like him lose that money so again we
have to stop putting ourselves in
position so when I say names like oh you
idiot and all that I'm not talking about
you individually I'm talking about the
decisions that we make remember this
isn't a decision
this isn't an incident where I had it
and I'm dancing and it it goes off it
said well I pull it out
I hit the button and I wiggle it for
everybody to see so he did it to himself
I'm not going to jump on he
he has to deal with with what's coming
and I know he has a lot of support
around him
and his friends can't be yes friends
I love my crew we fight and argue all
the time but you know what
they keep me they keep me in line yeah I
don't think you would surround yourself
with many people but it ain't about that
my friends keep me in line my friends
like hey that's what I mean you ain't
about that life no
you ain't about that life you don't need
to be doing that nah forget all that let
me tell you I like to I like to get it
cracking in the club right now you say
something to me but I got boy black we
ain't doing that tonight
but I just think we've sat around for
the last couple days and we've listened
to like everybody having an opinion
because everybody seems to have an
opinion when you make a mistake right
everybody seems to have an opinion when
you don't know the whole story and I get
a mistake was made it was it was a wrong
decision right but I hope the people
that are around him
are changing their opinions and and and
following a certain code of that they
all have to change right in terms of for
jaw to be successful
I look at things as a parent
as well and you talk about like what his
his parents are going through
you know
I hope that you know in that situation
they all are seeing the need to change
the decisions that they all are making
because it's impacting jaw it's
impacting his performance and it's hard
when everybody's against you and
everybody you know piles on the decision
that you made in the mistake and you
know I hope that when he does come back
and he makes different choices that we
all are able to see that and allow him
to grow I hope that we don't hold him to
this that that's not the first thing
that comes to our minds doesn't Define
him that it doesn't Define him because I
do believe that everybody deserves an
opportunity thank God that this wasn't
worse I think that's the biggest thing
thank God this wasn't worse and so
everybody deserves a platform and
opportunity to grow and to admit that
they were wrong and to go forward and I
think everybody is cheering for this
dude same same way when he came out of
Mercy State everybody's cheering for him
to be what we think that he's capable of
being
he was the same guy in the bubble I
played in the bubble he was the same guy
in the boat I remember everybody's like
oh the food's not good the beds are hard
he was like I'm fine
the bed's fine the food's fine I'm here
on a business trip to take care of
business and so that part of him is
still there we just need to come back to
the surface and like you said the people
around him I was thinking when Shaq was
talking Uncle Jerome was there
all day every day all day every day but
he he not that he held Shack accountable
but you need that that other grown up in
the room to be like yo Shaq slow down a
little bit you know whatever it might be
so it doesn't get to this point were you
that guy in the locker room before I
became that guy you became that guy I
became that guy but I wasn't that guy
when I first won the locker room yeah
but you asked the question it's in the
locker room that that didn't happen at
the arena right this happened at the
club what could it have been stopped if
you've seen if he's on if he's with you
in Miami or the Lakers right and you see
this young dude
kind of going this way Shaq's gonna say
yo Young fella you got it so it may not
get to this point you're gonna pull this
cocktail early but you also have to
listen
you know like you also have to be
willing to listen
and to learn and to listen to to guys
that have your best interests at heart
and
you know you're going to turn on and a
lot of times you're going to hear the
negativity that's being that's on the
television you're going to hear
everybody say what he should be doing or
what he wasn't doing or where he can you
know all that stuff I mean he's
deactivated his Instagram that's not the
reason that this is happening like the
the Instagram obviously allowed
everybody to see it but this was not
what caused this and so I think just in
in seeing and pointing the finger at the
right situation at yourself and
understanding taking accountability is
not the internet now you can shut it off
but you still got to deal with whatever
you don't have to deal with what you
have to deal with it not to go left it's
crazy because for the last couple years
we said Memphis needed a vet on the
court what's going to happen in the
playoffs
they need a vet off the court too so
this situation could have been slowed
down I believe
Memphis uh we'll see how long John is
out we are going to wait for more
information of course Steve and Adams
tried to talk to the team we'll see
seems like more information continues to
come out there are so many young Stars
their ceilings are seemingly Limitless
We are rooting for all of them we get to
watch Anthony Edwards tonight he's
played every game this year we'll have
more CarMax pregame show after this
[Music]